anyways Jacobs smart enough to get out
of there and which is also not really a
testament to his integrity right I mean
he's done these terrible things at the
behest of his mother because he wants
power and and he wants to get it without
deserving it and then you know he
finally goes too far and he hightailed
it out of there to his to another family
member to his mother's brother and so
it's not exactly the world's most heroic
story that's for sure and so now there's
an interlude here and this is a really
interesting interlude it's the story of
Jacob's Ladder so he's off to visit
Lebon or lab and who's his his mother's
brother and on the way he he has asleep
and he lighted upon a certain place and
tarried there all night because the Sun
was set and he took of the stones of
that place and put them for his pillows
which seems to indicate very bad
planning on his part and and lay down in
that place to sleep and he dreamed and
beheld a ladder set up on the earth and
the top of it reached to heaven and
beheld the angels of God ascending and
descending on it and behold the Lord
stood above it and said I am the Lord
God of Abraham thy father and the god of
Isaac the land were on thou liest to
thee I will give it and to thy seed and
so this story of Jacob's Ladder has
really possessed the imagination of the
West and there's a reason for that it's
because it's an archetypal story because
the idea of a ladder that reaches to
heaven is one of the oldest ideas of
mankind so you find it widely
distributed among the shamanic cultures
for example and it's a hallmark of
psychedelic experience that's another
way of thinking about it which is a very
peculiar thing so there's one
representation of of the ladder you see
god up at the top there peeking out from
the clouds now you know that's sort of
where we get the idea that God is in in
heaven and then heavens up in the sky
and and that's an easy story to make fun
of because you know we've gone up to the
moon and there's no God there and and
but but this this is not a reasonable
way of conceptualizing what these
experiences are about
these experiences what this is the
opening up there that's more like an
opening into an alternate dimension
that's a better way of thinking about
it's beyond like from from the
judeo-christian perspective one of the
things you have to understand is that
God is beyond space and time he's not in
the universe he's outside the universe
in some manner and so the idea that that
you have an experience of God and it's
up isn't the OP is the best that the
human imagination can do with what's
essentially a form of extra dimensional
experience or that's the the best way to
conceptualize it and these experiences
aren't rare you know they they make the
they make up the core of of the shamanic
tradition and so there's an intrusion of
the ancient shamanic tradition which is
tens of thousands of years old into the
biblical stories at this point
now why Jacob had a essentially shamanic
experience is very difficult to tell
because we don't know what these old
people were up to right and we don't
know how much of the archaic tradition
archaic religious tradition was still
extant at that point in time but we
certainly do know that our ancient
forebears were using psychedelic
substances constantly like Amanita
muscaria mushrooms for example which
were widely used in India before they
became extinct that's the theory anyways
that seemed to be the basis of the
chemical soma which much has been
written about and so we here ever this
as a dream or as a vision and perhaps
that's what it was but perhaps that
wasn't what it was either and perhaps it
was an experience that was induced by or
by the same processes that shamanic
people have always induced these
experiences and so we're gonna go
through this a little bit so anyways
there's a there's a connection between
heaven and earth that opens up that's
that's that's the that's the vision and
there's messengers moving up and down
now one way you can conceptualize that
is psychologically as we already
discussed that you know there there are
forces within you that are active and
alive and you can think of them in some
sense as messengers of the higher self
and so you could think about this as an
image of a psychological reality but
and so we can stick with that but but
here's some of the representations that
have been made I really like the one on
the right that's William Blake I like
the helix idea and I don't think that
that's that's fluke there are helixes
and double helixes and all sorts of
imaging imagery very ancient and very
modern that are associated with both
healing and with this kind of vision so
and you see it in the Blake
representation God is associated with
well really with the Sun and with light
and and you see that on the left as well
that wherever God is is where light is
and so that's a very interesting idea as
far as I'm concerned as well